там досі рівно земля щи недавно була
насипана могила відра зуб про ряд старий
водійським пам'ятникам воїнам вусами
синенькому центрі слов'янська після
звірами стас мулом і
від ості і міг елладі став і пошуку двох
десятків tell
раз на вигляд я volare ступку адже сама
суп із сокири живо купати цію місця
брюссельським апарат з там і
squid на підлозі і пальцем руку вночі
протвиц супом з місця бойових та похвали
тут своїх за згубних сердитих йому вірна і
російських громадян і коли почали
першими porsche та злих спочив їх йдуть
адже вона ж піали їх пару сиськи
персі загреблі був і в гарних гарних
струнах він їх просто відправляла до Росії
тут них у алли amis цілих wear давав
родичам на те були розвішані плакати
porsche та героїки закинуло задану бочку
народну республіку голову народну волю
були однак без нижчого забарвлення
валерій ступка то числа і не мішкан
Тесла військова зібрати їсть їх у володі
дали бешу керрик через гиблих просто
білля блокпост злетить вчилась шпалери для
багатих на сході України з я світінням
походження за гиблих з русі та кремль
такі дзвіночки витка даємо дочку з його
миротворця о 1 годині радикальні
націоналісти у Москві на круту
добровольців для боротьби в Україні volare
криниці це його побратими протерти на
грім пекельний засадах тазу рахунів по
жертв тут все чи з виглядом ще повернено і
сяду дому можна в гробу
он і пар ікона чи то ще донбас
донеччина то луганщина накласти до
України
історично полку процитовані воюють
так особу викликали на боротьба
поки volare кулаку вид права на вейну
наша кілька десятків добровольців
противенства і орджо ще по всій русі та
тисяч обожнюю чехова його ти навіть
людини і з dos видів бойових де в
афганістані та чечно важливі
або військові фахівці це в 1 city
також важливо мати
важливими вся кава фахівці у польшу
цеху а також чи важливі медика c
максимально баштовий контингент у нас
правді зловлю тебе всього в бойових умовах
людину еку будуть наш чат і європу чирик
у мирних умовах на там за два ти ж не
все одно навчитися за раз там уже
дістати нікель кисть наших скажемо
їх які тим людям нехай допоможе плач туго
тася річку але ваш вище повитих 3
максимально швидко увійти в дію 1040
апарати стив гру маріо на русі та ціни
вище його також британська журналістка
агаріо цілим розумом ловити самого
початку проте доказ nebula
аж поки навпроти театру мені донецьку
сепаратисти не попросив її розум із двома
колегам із подружжя животи конвой
пристрасті темрява тілам і вікінг видно було
видно стіну Батьківщини до Росії через
територію та а культовий pid контроль
українську силу в клей
нлп на це було вашим айза guf
поворотний момент
раб там розкрилася а ти що тут та й
російські бойовики
тапір головне харчування хто ті люди знай
монти патріоти гіпотеза свою справа і
скільки їх нас правді в поверхня
сепаратистів зазвучали називають менше
цифри ви не говорити про 2035 сотки в
russian server бойовиків проте ці вугілля
до чіпі дозріють всю їх може бути до 70
80 сотки
бандити торі пишемо сам битву з
еспандерами без вас самі 3 3
влада у ківі називаючи бойовики терористам
це званого чаю росію раз поливання
конфлікту особі можу початку ризиковий
експерт валентин бадрак у тему
адже після відбуття
малазійського пасажирського чи такому
скво за його словами та й дали посту чаю
бойовикам а вашого оружня не могли парі
канати серцем можна на види
коханих місцевим населенням купа
проросійські сепаратисти з 3g че
захопив і про зброю не російського
вирубні цба в українських ризикових нас
правді та dc про збрую accuracy я вже
зовсім не порожньо чаю українці мова ще
йдеться про ефективність зброї нової так
ще й про ефективність зброя
ми бачимо що ти а збруя на порядок
ефективніше ніш за передньою версією c
switch it pro прямі поставки російську
федерацію ті та зброї перу з особистим у
хрупова ним на сході України
угрупованням на сході України
бойовикам умови низький колаж не став і
this і пара тесті на сході україни c
вочевидь це допомогло українській армії
вдалося а ланки це місце в тому
страждання тут на пропані лісу
багатих то в сочі руку я знав їх рідних
бойовики
дістань його намахались а вранці від і
місця під своїм контролем вже нікуди не
було виходити і потім я їм уже нікуди
було вигляд ходять і to die кажу гіркін сам
обрау теніс те щоб на випаду як усі
донецька народна республіка про чоловіка
собів символ боротьби символ допомога русі
і
донецькій республіки розум з монументом
учасникам громадян sky провини ось це
монументом учасником громадянської війни
українців до виходить за допомогою умови
in scuto наших місцях будуть знайди але
громади 1 та масове пакування
сепаратистів і хоче будинках ти російським
сім'ям річки підозрює, що їх не син і
заглянув і на сході України
їх просять про їжака ти чимось допоміг ти
ідентифік уват і знає і не тіла за
хаббл їх